[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Brett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are going to be
answering your questions lots of good
questions
I predict that we're gonna spend most of
our time talking about marriage hmm
don't get into marriage a lot and I just
want to get into the first one well I
mean that's not even touch this feels so
abrupt I mean it feel like it that made
me feel anxious and uncomfortable oh my
goodness they're they're answering the
question alright like you got a disease
in like how are you how you doing I mean
like you don't want to know how I'm
doing I mean like we're here we're at
the studio you know it feels good to be
able to get out of the house and just
come to a place where there's no one I'm
related to directly you know what I'm
saying you know no one who's in my
immediate family they're all in another
place they're at the house that I was
just at that I wish that I shall return
to happily I I listen I hope to be
upbeat and I'm not I'm not going into
negative or complaining mode but
certainly seem like it the world but you
know I less I don't know what to say
I really don't I'm in pain I can tell
personally you didn't know what to say
that's why you were like literally I
looked and we were 30 seconds in you're
like let's get to the first question
yeah because like if that's an
indication of just how you feel right
now I'm overwhelmed man I mean it do you
want to talk about how we feel I mean
the last thing I want is to start
complaining about something associated
with my life at this point I'm not going
to do that
I'm not asking you for longer than a few
seconds I'm just you know everything
that's happening in the world and
everything that between what my personal
life and what's happening publicly I
mean there's just a lot going on this is
like all you have to do here's all you
guys it's so overwhelming all you have
to do and somebody look
at you and says what's wrong you just
say 2020 that's the everybody gets it
man just say 2020 but I don't even want
to say I did it's not that everything's
wrong there's a lot that's right this
happening it's just really it's positive
and overwhelming yeah and it's constant
and it should be you know I'm right
again I'm not complaining that that
every morning there's something there's
a new detail to grapple with in the news
and figure out how I personally am gonna
respond to that and then if we start
talking about how we how we as a as
companies or as leaders of a company are
gonna respond again I am not complaining
I am just acknowledging the fact that it
is a it is so complicated and
overwhelming and necessary and it you
know I'm not I'm not wishing for these
issues to go away I'm wishing for
coronavirus to go away well yeah you
know that's kind of what I was getting
at but I was talking about getting out
of the house I was like I think that
there's this the thing that we've been
talking about is boy it you know it
would be one thing for Humanity to be
added to like humanity addressing one
major issue is it's difficult enough for
Humanity to do that when you throw
multiple issues at Humanity yeah which
is what 2020 has decided to do let's
really dig in on systemic racism in
America and yeah you know yes that's the
right thing to do and it's and I'm not
trying I'm not trying to escape from
that constantly I you know I'm trying to
find ways and we are constantly talking
about ways that we can that we can
properly be engaged you just made it
sound like that's what we were about to
dig into just to clarified where that's
not what we're gonna do
well no it what we're gonna be answering
your questions but it's but it is but no
matter what you put out there's an
elephant in the room that is that matter
more than other things that matters the
most right now black lives matter more
than what we're going to talk about on
the show right today even even to the
point we're making a decision to talk
about anything that's like light-hearted
or funny it feels weird you just feels
weird feeling weird I mean it's like
yeah and I'm everybody's got stuff
they're going through personally too and
everybody's got their you know their own
[ __ ] they're dealing with and then it's
yeah you're right
2020 is is is a doozy but I just don't I
don't want to I don't want to come
across as complaining about it because
it's it's such an important movement and
now is the time and we we all needed to
make sure we're taking care of ourselves
and we're having this we're having space
well I think those but when we come to
these microphones and then it's just
like it's tough to know especially when
it's like do you feel like everything
can be scrutinized or criticized when
you say something into a microphone
mm-hmm yeah well I think that's the fit
that's the temptation the temptation
especially for white people who have the
privilege to just check out of the
conversation if they want to if they
conclude that they don't have there's
nothing personal at stake they can be
like I'm just can we just move on can we
just talk about something else and I
think your point is is like no we're not
moving on and we're not we're not moving
on until real change it has has taken
place you know that's why I reckon it
will be directly related to this stuff
and if you feel that as a white person
you feel that fatigue setting in that
like I do I gotta I gotta think about
this and I
I was just trying to figure out how to
argue with my uncle about coronavirus
and now I gotta argue with him about it
you know it's like yeah unfortunately
unfortunately or fortunately for better
or for worse yeah and I do think for
better as you what you were getting at
it's like you got we gotta keep talking
about it because it's just not something
where there was this movement and
everybody got excited and put stuff on
Instagram and then all of a sudden it's
like okay we good now no no we're not
good that's the point
yeah we're not good it isn't good but
how do we transition to having this ear
biscuit be about something else for a
second and I don't you know I just say I
don't want to defend that decision I
just want to have a conversation you
know we have you know well I think the
question itself will demonstrate the
awkwardness of the transition so without
further ado why don't you just ask the
first question see we could it we could
already been halfway through this but
now I think I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad
I'm I'm glad that we didn't know ask
this question
praise sharp by the way
shout out to praise sharp she was the
solver of the of the riddles that in the
mythical society that led to uncovering
the fact that we were doing a live
broadcast of a screening of me watching
Ferris Bueller's Day Off for the first
time ever yeah and all the clues were
wrapped up in that stereoscopic viewer
which featured movies from the 80s I'd
never seen but wasn't there like a there
were a number of steps and she and there
was one on GMM right yeah there was a
there was a clue on GMM that tied back
to the stereoscopic viewer and there
were a number of layers and we could
watch it happen in the discord when it
was being solved that's the kind of
stuff that's happening in the mythical
society when you go crazy you figured it
out solving mysteries your question how
old were you when you had your first
celebrity crush
who was it hashtag ear biscuits I didn't
have like an immediate answer to this I
really had to think about it the first
person I thought about was uh was Daisy
Duke from the Dukes of Hazzard
okay well but I mean she's a
controversial choice yeah well I'm just
as a kid i watch that show and she ward
what became to be known as daisy dukes
right but all I remember feeling was
just weird and tingly and I didn't
really understand or want to come to
grips with anything that was happening
and that was not a what was that how old
are you talking about uh I mean that's
pretty young right I don't know what
years but I I think my first real crush
that I remember is Vicki the robot
featured in the television show small
wonder the girl who played the lead yeah
the robot the robot
did you watch the show right I mean it
started in 1985 yeah I went to like 19 I
didn't watch it religiously oh I watched
it as a religion i worshiped her as a
celebrity crush because she was a robot
no I I don't know I just I was like oh
she's cute and she's she's kind of
robotic it's kind of it's kind of cool I
remember being embarrassed that someone
would find out that I and that I had a
crush on a robot girl and it was I'm
trying but I read a little bit about the
story that she was an actor well yeah I
knew it was an actress but like so it
would have been weird to have it out on
the actor who was playing her I had a
crush on the robot I had a crush on the
character I liked how she acted like you
wanted a robot girlfriend yeah that is
not a good thing no no it's nice if you
if you have if you are the cut if you
have a robot girlfriend or if you've got
one of those real dolls I'm not saying
that's wrong but I'm but what I'm
getting at is if you wanted a woman that
you could program and control that
that's that that's a right in place of a
of an actual woman
that could get problematic that could
that could reveal some some bad
tendencies about yourself which was the
point of that robot girlfriend song yeah
he was a guy who wanted to turn her to
turn her off when he wanted to I just
right I just thought that she was cute
man I thought it was cute how there's
definitely more going on than that
though now that you've talked about it
okay either something in there her so
her dad was like a technological
advanced electronics guy like he made
her and then he made her as a robot and
then didn't tell anybody so as a family
you know they had a they had a
flesh-and-blood son
they had Vicky the robotic daughter and
he was Vicky I couldn't he did for
something VI CCI
virtual know very ingenuitive the new
ventriloquism but they kept it a secret
that she wasn't that she wasn't human
yeah hence the whole point of the show
right he has a lot of tension there yeah
I don't remember the first crushes that
I remember were just girls that I went
to school with like you know and I and I
remember I remember like being in first
grade and having crushes on girls you
you picked tall girls which makes sense
yeah then used to when you started
dating you started dating short girls
right yeah and you never dated a tall
girl
well you there was that one girl in
college that was kind of tall that you
wanted to date yeah but she didn't date
me no she didn't want to date you I
didn't mean to bring it up but did she
tell you I don't know I never told her
that I wanted a day or I thought you
wrote her a letter or something I
thought you I thought you made a play I
like you check yes or no well I've
definitely would not have done that
specifically no no it never became a
thing it never became a thing well she
was she was as close as you got to date
in a tall girl right but I mean I'm in
first grade having a crush on Lisa who
was in second grade
who
boy I wish you and she was so tall and I
just think that was coincident really
she was she was the only tall girl that
I had a crush on growing up we named
another well I mean the the girl I'm
trying not to name names anymore because
well you have a tendency to thank me
first and last names you don't have to
name the girl who you have would always
have dreams about flying to her house
she wasn't tall she was tall no she
wasn't tall her
she wasn't short five four maybe as an
adult ho she's taller than man five five
max Oh hundred percent I don't fi for
maybe I just watched her in your drink
your memory is flawed but what I'm
saying is Liberty Cross celebrity
crushes I remember and I had to look her
name up because I as soon as I read this
question celebrity crush there was a
model that I remember really really
liking in the 80s mm-hmm as I was sort
of becoming you know myself you know and
because I guess in 1987 you know I'm 10
years old like I said I was already
liking girls before that but they're
closer and closer I got to like 12 the
stronger and stronger these urges got um
Christy Turlington she's still around
well yeah she's not dead yeah I mean I
think she might still model yeah well
yeah I mean I'm sure she does in some
capacity III remember Christy Turlington
but she's like one of those classic
supermodels of the 80s that like
alongside Cindy Crawford etc yeah you
know but I just remember seeing her as a
as a boy and just thinking wow she's
very pretty I mean I thought those
things too but I would it didn't
transfer into a crush because I would
never I could never date a supermodel
well I would go line disconnects I would
stop at the magazine section at the
grocery store and because she was on a
bunch of covers right
I would go to that section where there
was beautiful women on the covers of
magazines and I'm not talking about the
porn section because that's not in the
grocery store I'm not talking about like
jugs I'm talking about like vogue yeah
you know there's we already knew that
beautiful the cover and I would just
would just stare you you wouldn't pull
the magazine down and thumb through it
well cuz I think it's important to
understand that you know and this is the
case in most places but like you could
you didn't walk around Buies Creek and
find a woman that looked like that like
that does what you know we didn't we
weren't in Los Angeles or whatever you
know it's like this was like it was this
something that you're like does this
really exist and of course now we know
technically no it doesn't exist because
it's been manipulated this lighting is
perfect she's got on this makeup in
exactly the right way trying I'm trying
to figure out I think I know the answer
what's more problematic you being
enamored by this this airbrushed woman
or me being enamored by a robotic girl
well I think what well I think what I'm
discovering right now is that and I
think it's one of the reasons that and I
wasn't this is not the point that I was
trying to make and I'm not trying to
make a woke point that's not my
intention but I do think it's
interesting that just as this young boy
walking through the grocery store while
your mom's pick up picking out viana
sausages you're sitting there with your
little Vienna sausage in there in the in
the magazine section staring at these
manufactured beautiful women like
Christy Turlington and just thinking
that this is I remember thinking things
like this is why I exist yeah it's like
III remember thinking that like this is
what I'm here for
yeah to find that and it's a that is not
a good that is just not a good thing to
be thinking right to think that this is
some manipulated why is your watch
talking your watch is trying to give you
some advice here
Wow why would cereal you asking me if I
was asking her I said something that
sounds like Siri but now I'm going to
put her to sleep sorry this is like
putting Vikki to sleep they did that you
know I just said Vicki do not disturb me
and so she will never interrupt us again
until I turn it back on I don't know
what my point was my point was is that
it probably wasn't a healthy thing but I
specifically remember when I saw her on
TV because she was in a bunch of
commercials she was in a bunch of ads I
mean I didn't know her name I had to
look her name up I didn't know her name
at the time was like that that girl yeah
that's what I'm about yeah you were I
wouldn't call it an obsession but I mean
we interacted with the female form
different differently expand please I'm
just saying I didn't I didn't I just
didn't I didn't gawk at the at the
magazine's like I would I was too
embarrassed to do that I was embarrassed
that I that I liked Vicki well you were
no one you know the world anyone to know
and not to get graphic I'm just being
honest here in other words when you as a
young boy looked at Vicki you didn't
think boy I wonder what that robot looks
like under her clothes right and that
and I'm being honest with you yeah
that's the kind of thing that I was
thinking when I saw the ad I was like
okay what else is there that's just
that's that's how I'm wired yeah it's
interesting that I had shame in just
having a crush on Vicki I wouldn't I
wouldn't have wanted anyone to know and
I would have denied it I don't think I
mean I didn't talk I didn't tell you the
girls that I had a crush on not until
like probably middle school at that
point I was pretty open about it the
girls that like in school that I had a
crush on like I didn't want anyone to
know that and I remember when including
them yeah and even in like middle school
when people started pairing up and like
oh she's my girlfriend we're going
together like I was really nervous that
if I when I got a girlfriend I
like my family was gonna find out it's
such a weird thing I remember just being
so nervous that they would be like oh do
you you've got a girlfriend what's her
name you you weren't scared of them
finding out you were scared of having to
talk about it it was like revealing a
part of myself and it's like they it's
like I felt like they would know
something about me that I didn't want
them to know that I had a girlfriend
that I liked a girl that I wanted to
hold a girl's hand I mean I do I didn't
want to talk to my parents a you know
but I was embarrassed that they would
know like yeah girl well I I think that
that is normal I think that the idea
every every time I want to talk to
either one of my boys about girls mm-hmm
immediate embarrassment right yeah so I
think that that's yeah totally normal
I don't it would be I think it would be
a little bit odd if they weren't
somewhat embarrassed about it
right I remember I remember being at a
baseball game and it was when I was
dating amber and we were watching the
baseball game you were one of the
players and your mom was there and I
remember what if the play I remember you
say that like it's some accomplished
holding a cut no one from the team yeah
I didn't apply for the team I didn't
care for it you know because you
misunderstood it wasn't an application
was just showing up where's the
application I can't be on this I learned
enough about baseball to know that I
needed to be in the stands holding hands
and my girlfriend I I'm sure amber held
my hand I didn't hold her hand
you're talking about middle school
baseball yeah when I dated amber okay
and your mom would agree your mom was
sitting there in the bleachers and I'm
sitting there and Amber's holding my
hand and I just felt so embarrassed that
your mom is gonna see me holding hands
with my girlfriend I get that yeah I
guess that's normal I I don't I think
that and I know that sometimes you feel
like you you need to check how how weird
how weird you are because you have sets
of things that are like okay yeah that's
different
but I'm never unusual I never looked at
that's not I never looked at girls on a
mat
using cover and thought man I just want
to keep thinking about her I just felt
like that's a woman yeah I'm a boy
that's a woman that's right that's what
I was thinking that that is a woman
that's what that's what I was thinking
yeah I was like why doesn't she look I'm
discreet I'm just gonna stay away from
the hole that you're digging for
yourself I don't I mean why did all I've
done has been I've been honest about the
fact that as far back as I can remember
when I saw a beautiful woman I was very
attracted to them you know what might
make this better
asking another question which will
answer after the break
beep-boop 2488 says let's talk marriage
okay well this will this smooth things
over if we talk about our long-standing
love affair with our wives my wife what
is not threatened by the things that I
thought as a eight-year-old in the
grocery store I didn't know her at the
time I'm not talking about our wives
listening I'm talking about everyone
else listening how like our interactions
with females can be appropriate and
mutually edifying yeah and it not be
based on some farce or your own needs or
mine of a robot just to clarify though
we've talked about a woman on a
television show and a woman in a
magazine I'm very so those are not
introductions I know right when you talk
about women in a magazine you know and
like it self image and the female form
and stuff like that you know I'm
starting to get nervous
I understand let's talk a marriage I've
been with my husband since I was 19 now
she doesn't say how old she is she could
be 20 but let's assume it's longer than
that let's talk about how crazy it is to
grow up together become adults together
become parents together keep the spark
alive and not kill each other in the
process yes that is the goal but first
we're going to what are we what do we
what are we doing today we just want to
urge you to go to mythical calm and just
scroll around just scroll around
you'll find stuff that you didn't know
we were selling that happens to me when
I go there haha I'm like yeah that's
great rep rep mythical rep your boys it
I
there's something about merch that you
know you you really you can feel
connected to us we crafted something we
mailed it to you you're wearing it or
you're using it and you're spraying it
are you putting it through your hair or
on your lips and it's it's a connection
connect to us
well I in our stuff that's an
interesting perspective I mean I don't
disagree with it but I was just gonna
say it there is cool clothes you watch
the show but then it's like you can wear
the ethos that's also true I like that
mythical calm okay again the question is
talking about growing up together when
you got married young I mean at 19 right
yeah so my wife had just turned I don't
want to get this wrong I think she just
turned 20 she she had turned to get me
she had turned 20 in December 1999 and
then we got married in June 2001 I was
like 20 I guess I was 23 at the time
well I was 21 I turned 22 on our on our
honeymoon yeah because I'm never happy
year older than you and got married a
year after you so there's like eight
yeah that way you know we just we and
we've been Chris now been married 20
years right and you've been married 19
19 years I've been married as long as
this woman lived before she got married
and I think maybe she has to because
that's kind of wrapped up in her
question she's been through a lot
well this made me think about we did
talk about this a little bit in the in a
Lost years podcast just the idea of
growing up together and you know the
thing about getting married jung-hee
is you haven't become you you haven't
become the adult that you're going to be
right and they're still at 19 at 20 at
early 20s there's still a lot of change
I mean there's gonna be there's a lot of
change at any point in your life but
especially at that time like you haven't
lived alone like you haven't you haven't
been an adult with responsibilities and
all of a sudden you're two adults for
the responsibilities figuring life out
together a lot of people get married at
that age get divorced because once they
kind of figure out who they are who they
are they're like oh this is not gonna
work but a lot of people if you're you
know if you're blessed as we have been
to kind of be able to grow up together
and as you learn and as you grow it
enhances the connection that which is I
think what has happened but the the
thing that this made me think of is
something that Jessie and I have started
doing which is I don't remember why we
started I know that she had been
watching the first season or the last
season how many seasons there have been
of this married at first sight
this have not heard of this competition
show it's not a competition I don't know
if it's a Netflix original or if it's
just on Netflix now we watch it we watch
it on Netflix and we just started
whatever the latest season season 2 I
don't know so at first I was just like
me and her like to watch trash we'd like
to watch trashy reality TV together and
laugh at it like we watched The Bachelor
together we even watched that Bachelor
the one where they did was basically
music it was American Idol makes me
cheap at bachelor and they put the
couples together and they had to sing
together oh and then had people come and
judge it and it's just like horrible it
was a cringe fest but we we like to
watch things that are bad because it
entertains us makes you feel better
about not being that cringe not being on
that show yeah but this show which I
just assumed was gonna be another one of
these shows the premise of the show is
they go to a city so this season they're
in Charlotte North Carolina
and all these single people apply and
all these single people are like I want
to get married
I'm
ready to get married and there's a team
of experts who are the hosts of the show
oh and they go through all these people
interview them I don't know all the
process they narrow it down to these
four couples that they have out of so
they pair people together and is this
over the course of the season or is this
know if episode pisode one is the
selection of the four couples okay now
let me explain to you this is how it
works and this is episode two episodes
is this called naked and afraid' because
that's how I would describe my honeymoon
no but that yeah that's you can watch
that after episode two is the wedding of
the four couples and this is on their
wedding day is the first time they've
ever seen each other never it like when
the bride walks down the aisle that is
the first time that the the groom is
seeing her
it just doesn't I mean my knee-jerk
reaction is that doesn't sound like they
have a very high opinion of marriage
it's like yeah let's let's give this a
shot that is what I thought going in and
that may still be true but let me do it
it's just like oh this will be fun we
can always just get divorced now it's a
great way to start a marriage no no no
before you judge it you're judging it
hard right now I'm judging I'm saying
this is the assumptions that I'm
bringing to ya and that's what makes it
so entertaining now the way that the
show works is and this is if you have a
certain view of marriage that you would
think that this is wrong and maybe you
fall into this category and I would
probably have fallen into this category
before I started watching it I think
differently about it now what this show
has changed that what do you think about
marriage oh yeah I'm gonna explain that
so the way that it works is they're
married for eight weeks and at the end
of eight weeks you decide if you're
going to stay married to get divorced
that's the season of television right
and so I don't know what episode we're
on right now but like the second episode
and so our cameras are following them
honeymoon like we just last night we
watched the beginning of the honeymoon
like and so there's these questions like
are we gonna have sex on the first night
Luke we literally met this afternoon at
our
wedding are we gonna have sex and then I
don't want it I'm not gonna spoil
anything but there's like who's gonna
have sex who's not gonna have sex and it
sounds like I'm talking about a trashy
show right I would be so afraid to
forget my wife's name oh that's that's
one of the that's what happens when they
walk down the aisle they introduced
themselves it's like I'm Natalie it's
like it's like Oh still sounded pretty
gross you know what you know when they
find out their last name and again
there's some it's at least this at this
season weather in Charlotte it's ah it's
very traditional it's like for couples
heterosexual couples men and women and
then all the women are taking the
husband's last name so the way that
they're like we now introduce to you mr.
and mrs. Johnson and the woman's like
Johnson she's like responding it's great
television let me just say it's great
television because of that because you
put yourself in this and you're like
what would it be like okay now I just
thought this was gonna be trashy reality
TV that I was just gonna be laughing at
the whole time the reason my life my
wife likes to watch it with me is I weep
when I watch and I don't mean like I
don't mean like I she'll look over at me
and like I've got like tears am i okay
like multiple times while watching this
[ __ ] like you got to yeah well I got
tears cuz I'm laughing right now but I
got tears in my eyes yeah I'm making you
cry so I don't know but I've been trying
to figure out what's going on and Jessie
we've been talking about this and in
there's I think there's a number of
things first thing is it's like what's
going on in your heart yeah what like
why am i responding to the show in this
way and so what one thing is is that it
has hit me that these marriages which
are arranged by someone else yeah are
very similar to my marriage and let me
explain what I mean by that meaning that
when you're young you don't know what
the hell you want I mean you don't know
what the hell you want when you're old
either but especially when you're young
and you're figuring out who you are
think about how differently I think
about literally everything that I did
when I was 23 right 20 years have gone
by I changed in many different ways ways
that we've talked about on the show
still married to the same woman who has
also changed in similar in different
ways yeah and there's this idea that oh
well you got to be exactly sure about
this person you got to know everything
there is to know about them you should
probably live with them before you get
married because you need to know what
kind of habits they have this show calls
that into question right and calls into
question that it's really about someone
who is the individuals that make up the
marriage
are ready for the commitment that
marriage is right they are met there
they are prepared to be like I know
you're not perfect I mean first of all a
lot of the things we've been talking
about is the process of having experts
select your spouse for you is probably
at least as reliable as the process of
you selecting your spouse for yourself
let me just say that that's what that's
a premise that's a working theory that I
have yeah and I'm not talking about we
should go back to arranged marriages I'm
just saying that if you wanted to submit
yourself to this process you like to
think that no no I would be better at
making this decision because I'm
rational I want to make sure I'm in love
with somebody whatever your reasons
would be I submit that that initial
spark that makes you fall in love with
with somebody while it is important it
isn't the thing that we talked about
this before but it isn't the thing that
maintains a 20-year marriage
yeah so you know let's talk more about
the commitment component but I do think
that when I was you know trying to
figure out if I was gonna propose to
Christy if we were meant to be together
you know I was doing lots of math I was
doing lots of analysis right and even
even when we got engaged like we went we
went through premarital counseling which
I highly recommend because it can raise
flags that could lead to light you know
what let's turn back now you know let's
make it as an informed decision as we
can about the commitment we want to make
I feel like some of what these experts
mmm that you're describing did
we tried to Christine I tried to do in
our premarital counseling like we went
through this book and it was like it was
a workbook maybe he went through the
same workbook Cameron what it was called
like a Tom Nelson it wouldn't know but
it was in an oh you mean like a putt Tom
Nelson evangelical publisher it was like
preparing preparing for marriage or
something like yeah I think it was a it
was from a Christian worldview yeah but
it was very practical like it you know
it forced well it it guided us to talk
about things like six yeah like our
expectations for sex but then smaller
things like habits like things that
matter to you
small things that are a big deal to you
things that you know that it can be
annoyances like how you deal with money
yeah yeah yeah you know all the endings
putting a plan and points of thought
that could be points of choice to
conflict you put a plan in place it's
like okay we can we hear each other and
we agree and we're we're we're planning
our future but we're also analyzing like
there is a chance and it felt very slim
that our counselor who was walking us
through this would be like you know what
you're not right folder pull up pull the
plug you're not right for each other
I'm sure some counselors do that ones
that were really bold I it's a I still
think that seems like a really great
idea
like I would this television show not
the television show because it's great
it is a great idea freedom it's free
Mehldau premarital certification I won't
even say Council yeah yeah like some
sort of sort of third-party
certification i I mean as my kids get
older and they're like as they start
finding partners I'll be like can you
agree to a third-party certification I'm
making this up right now because I don't
like this go on this television show
okay yeah they you just go on there but
okay I agree I get what you're saying I
agree with all of it I mean I'm
interested in the commitment component
but like tell me what you're learning
well just to finish your to add to your
thought to finish your thought you
finished my thought to add to your
thought finish him I
think that then again I don't these
experts how qualified are they I don't
know as they got PhDs and [ __ ] but how
does that certification process that
they are putting these people through
compared to this sort of the very small
focus group of the two of you and a
counselor how does it compare and I'm
saying that my suspicion early on
now first of all one of the things is
like whose don't say together like right
that's one of the fun things about
watching it and Jesse and I were like oh
this couple I think they're gonna be
okay
like we say things I think they're gonna
be okay in this couple it's like ooh
like he's he's really organized and
she's not right and so you would be like
well why did they put them together and
you know sometimes it's a huge problem
and sometimes it's not it really depends
and maybe a reason why they put it is
because the producers over wrote and
that's the expert that's the thing that
I talked to Jesse about I was like what
do you think don't you agree that
because I get into the production side
of I was like don't you think that they
made the people on this television show
sign something that said that they
understood that one of the criteria for
them casting okay well them coming
together companies people together is an
entertainment quality right sure it's in
the fine print something yes you will be
matched according to your compatibility
but you will also be matched according
to entertainment value so and they
probably didn't say that part I probably
said with the prerogative of the
executive your vices so it's probably
covered I'm sure they've got that
covered Netflix or whoever makes the
show now all that means said I think the
reason that I get teary eyed and first
of all it there's like one couple that I
don't there's they elicit nothing I have
no sympathy for them I don't really like
either of them that's what they sound
like they're meant for each other and I
think they also I think they had the
smallest chance of staying together but
these other three couples it's like when
like the bride walked down the aisle and
like the husband saw her it was like I
found myself and just I do this at
weddings in general I get kind of
teary-eyed at weddings but I found
myself first time happening I was like
what the hell is happening to me right
now why am i responding in this way
and I think that it has a lot to do with
thinking about those moments in my
marriage in the way that like Jesse and
I did not know what we were doing but
the same sort of like deer in headlights
what have I gotten myself into am I
ready for this that is so
sensationalized and exaggerated in this
show is something that I felt about the
whole period of my life of you know we
got we got married women got married
because of the culture that we were in
we got you know one of the reasons we
got married when we got married is
because at the time we were abiding by a
worldview that said that premarital sex
wasn't part of God's plan right it's
like you want to have sex you got to be
in a committed marriage specifically not
just a relationship but a marriage and
that had a that had a deep impact on our
decision-making abilities exactly again
I'm saying all this because you may look
at this show like you did and like I did
before I watched it and said this is
ridiculous why would anybody make a
decision to get married based on some
experts on a television show and then
you start thinking about the reasons
that you get married and I say none of
this to say that I mean I was madly in
love with my wife still AM was drawn to
her we were compatible we what you
couldn't stay away from each other we
couldn't imagine not having a life
together all those things were in place
but so much of that was just influenced
by the nature of who we were at the time
and these could these cultural pressures
and expectations in our worldview right
and it would but that got us into it
right but none of that stuff it doesn't
none of that stuff keeps you in it that
stuff can that kind of throws you over
the threshold but it doesn't keep you in
the room but yeah but their mayor they
got married it in Episode one and by
episode eight they're deciding if
they're gonna stay together but really
that means is like we're gonna pretend
to be married for eight weeks no legally
binding oh I know but but they they've
kind of thrown out the window they're
like we're at let's let's play marriage
let's be married in an
experiment for television for eight
weeks and then we'll decide if we really
want to be married but to tie it in with
our story one of the girls on the show
one of the women she's 27 years old is a
virgin who has saved herself for
marriage okay so that feels like there's
more at stake because she's gonna she's
gonna give up her virginity which is
very important to her
according to her worldview and then not
stay with this guy because after eight
weeks it seems like maybe it's not it's
gonna be a little bit difficult well I
think the fact that is the question if
she the fact that she said okay again
I'm not making a statement I'm not
promoting the purity culture thing I'm
just saying that the fact that she has
saved herself for marriage increases the
chances that their marriage will go
beyond the eight weeks because he's got
more did she continue to did she did she
wait to have sex until has she waited so
far they have not consummated yet yeah
okay that makes sense and that's support
at the point that I'm in that supports
my my assertion they will though you
think they're gonna hold out she's gonna
hold out for eight weeks I guarantee you
she's gonna do it she's already
basically said that she's going to do it
oh yeah yeah cuz they aren't because
once she once she realized that she
wants to have sex with him she's already
married to him and according to her
worldview not typically how it happens
is she she's she got the okay as soon as
she got married to him yeah but she's
probably if she subscribes to that
worldview I think she's probably also
subscribes to the worldview that she
can't get divorced
unless there's infidelity so unless he
cheats on her in the next eight weeks on
this television show which is probably
not gonna happen because there's cameras
on him the whole time she's gonna be
married to this guy for a long time and
I'm not in a lot of times that that
doesn't work out well I'm just saying
I'm not judging it good or bad I'm just
saying that that decision makes it more
likely for her to stick around in the
marriage room for longer all right but
how many garlis how many of these
contestants
though you don't say contestants man our
acting couples marry couples what what
are they saying about commitment things
that make me cry
really so said they're like we're theirs
they're sincere they're not like just
tiptoeing around like hey this is an
experiment they're not acting the way
that I'm saying no they're acting like
our lives depend on this relationship
the reason that I like it is because the
people on the show the reason I feel
about it differently like when I watch
the bachelor or the Bachelorette or the
bachelor in paradise which is the
trashiest trash I've never watched me
and Jesse even watched that I'm watching
small wonder reruns we watched that too
hot to handle that I tweeted about which
was I mean the whole point of the show
was to be trash when we watched those
shows we just I just judge the people
the contestants constantly and I'm just
like how stupid do you have to be to go
on this show and like these people don't
understand anything about life these
people on married at first sight like
it's a different it's a different kind
of person like they are taking it very
seriously it isn't like out in other
words when you watch The Bachelor you're
like how many of these women what's a
bachelor how many of these men are on
this show for clout so they can be yeah
so they can become reality TV stars that
you don't get that vibe at all from
these pits like I did this because I
want to be married because I see myself
as a married person and I haven't had
any luck in that in my own life trying
it my way so now why don't I let these
experts do it for me
and they see not that I don't believe in
I mean I don't know what I think about
arranged marriages but I think that I I
do think I have this belief which I
haven't thought about or like asserted
I'm just gonna vomit this out and see if
I can make sense of it like everything
else I say I've I've been like you know
I I believe that arranged marriages
could work just as well as an arranged
marriages now I'm not I don't want to
get into like who's a
ranging it like I'm not I'm not weighing
in on that but like if you put two
people to get to a process and you're
you're on board for that and it's and
it's um it's by your volition I think
what people are equally committed
because a lot of times both people leave
arranged marriage in marriage in general
can be kind of tied into this
patriarchal thinking but so we're
talking about in the power feet well I
guess what I want to pull you we want to
be married
I mean just like in that show I I have
thought in general it it could probably
work I think it's part of my I guess my
experience kind of impacts my opinion in
that like Christina were talking the
other day about this this a couple and I
know I know nothing about her she was
like so and so as announced they're
getting a divorce they're like a very
it's like I'm the their motivational
speaking couple that they talk about
relational dynamics and after like
almost 20 years of marriage they've
decided to just be friends and I'm like
listen I don't know anything about this
but if you break up if you divorce after
that long and you just want to be
friends it's like when you add the
detail that they have a public persona
of of giving marriage advice and then
that makes sense that I'm just saying
there's an ulterior motive to to
maintain a friendship to prove that like
my voice is still valid when it comes to
relationships but that's a hard thing to
believe that like you've been married 20
years and you just get divorced and you
we're still best friends and raising our
kids together it's like that's freaking
complicated I'm just suspicious but I
know nothing decides what I just said I
know nothing except the thing my wife
said to me offhanded I've come to a firm
conclusion but I told Christie tacked on
to that conversation I was like we've
been through so much together and I can
understand being married for 20 years
and I mean we've changed so much that we
could have changed in ways that were so
different and divergent that I we would
get a divorce like
but I'm so grateful that we haven't
changed in exactly the same ways and we
haven't changed at exactly the same
times but we've gone through so much of
it together that we're still very much
in it together and we're we're like
we're on the same page the book is a big
book I mean you know the page you know
it's not like teetering on a on a on the
pinhead that you're trying to like just
to stay on the same page you don't have
to be in a you don't have to believe the
same thing about everything you don't
have to have the same instincts you
could you know have to be the same
person to to make it last because
Christian are not the same person but
we've changed in this it's in a in in
like a dance there's a give-and-take and
there's a there's a listening and
there's a sharing and there's a it's
undergirded by this commitment I guess
that we are in this together we are
together we are going to go through this
together and it's gonna when it's really
hard and it it's really yeah at times
it's really hard
well there was this when if you come
through it if you come through each of
those things it makes it you can go into
the next one with that much more
confidence the next marriage the next
trial first marriage what you did wrong
go to the second one a lot of people do
say that I'll do that my second marriage
I want I want to stay here I know we're
staying with this question but I want to
stay here because one other thing I I
don't remember the name of the study I
don't know where this was Jesse told me
about it but there was some relationship
expert slash psychologist who said that
they could look at they basically set
couples down and had them communicate
with each other on video and this person
could watch like 20 seconds of the
mm-hmm yeah I feel like I could do that
too and decide if they're gonna stay
together and make a very accurate
prediction as to whether or not they
would be together five years from now
and and I don't I'm not getting the
numbers exactly right but it was like an
unbelievably short amount of time of
seeing them together it could make a
very predictable a very reliable
prediction about how long they were
gonna say get it well what would you
look for because I feel like I could do
that
well the piers the thing I know what I
would look that's what this show that's
one of the things you're doing as you
watch the show and here's I firmly
believe that while you could get into
some really like analytical it's not
it's a vibe and and now it is based hold
on oh could see this is important
because there are things like me and
Jesse have talked about this lately
we've been like you know how sometimes
like you know someone and you get this
you get a vibe from them and you and you
can be like I just I don't I think this
person is duplicitous or I think that
this person there's something off about
this person yeah in their character and
you can kind of sense it but then you're
like if that feels that feels judgmental
I'm not basing that on anything other
than just a conversation I had with them
and me and you have noticed this there's
been a couple of times when like we met
with someone in like a business capacity
and then will come out of a meeting and
we'll be like I don't get it I don't get
a good vibe from that guy and it might
be that and some it but what I have
learned is that whatever is happening
when I say that to myself is more
reliable than the to our conversation
then mute that mean you might have
afterwards trying to rationalize our way
into thinking whether or not somebody is
worth working with and that's what I
think this psychologist is picking up on
is that the human capacity for
processing things in a way that you
cannot even articulate is way under
appreciated by most people in other
words the vibe that you get from someone
is
very often reliable that doesn't mean
you're gonna be wrong sometimes but I'm
just saying that I think that we tried
it so we talked about this because
there's one the one couple that we don't
think I just the look on his face when
she says something the look on her face
the physical just the way that they seem
to be connecting and then there's
another couple that is immediately
you're like they they got it they're
gonna be together a long time I can see
the way they interact to me it comes
down to I mean if you can and I don't
know how long it takes it varies from
person to person but if you can tell
somebody's like a genuine good person
you know but I'm if I was trying to be
specific about my analysis to me
something that would be a telltale sign
was like being able to quantify humility
like if if I could you know if if if I'm
listening in on a conversation and it's
you could tell that they don't seem like
they're they're asserting that they've
got it all figured out or that they're
the type of person that can say they're
sorry you know you got it you got to be
willing to be humble and admit your
mistakes to stay in it in a vibrant
relationship and you know I think we
when you've been married as long as we
have we know we really know our our
partners right like I know Christy I was
gonna say inside and out but then that
would have been weird right well but
sort of true it's totally true but I
didn't mean it in that way get your mind
off the magazines you dirty-minded know
boy I know I didn't say like I mean we
know each other
we know everything we feel like we can
predict what the other person would say
or think or interact and what like we
know what the other person is capable of
as friends like people think our
friendship is so extraordinary for that
reason but it's like I feel like that's
really a requirement for marriage for a
long-lasting marriage is like
people like and I guess that's why
people say that about our friendship
that's like because it's not a marriage
and people don't invest that much in
friendship but I think you have to have
that in a marriage in it but such a high
standard but I think no but what but
what I'm seeing in these couples is like
literally okay they just got married but
they're not I mean your hold on but they
got they just got married and then they
after they get married the camera
follows them is they walk back through
everybody we present to you mr. and mrs.
Johnson they walk through everybody and
then they go to this little they all get
married at the same place someplace in
Charlotte and then they have their first
date and then they know they're just
sitting there talking to each other and
there's like a bottle of champagne like
they do it all the couples have to do it
and it's just like I looked at the way
that these two people interacted with
each other in the first moments of ever
meeting and I feel like I can make a
reliable prediction and that's not what
the psychologist was doing so I don't
think I what I agree with everything
that you're saying that the key to like
a continuing marriage is this learning
about each other is communicating but
I'm talking about compatibility that
gives you the right runway to be able to
establish those things that you're
talking about I feel like it's something
that you can just sense in a sixth sense
kind of way now there are some people
and this is the cake is unfair to put it
on the first time you meet television
after you've gotten married because
there's plenty of no I'm just saying I'm
not saying it's 100 percent right
what I'm just saying that there is this
I you can sense compatibility pretty
quickly but there's lots of people who
get married young did not realize that
they weren't I mean just because you're
the two people eligible people who get
married in your small town in the same
year doesn't mean that you're compatible
right mm-hmm it's it's statistics you
just were in the right place at the
right time then you start trying to
figure out are you actually compatible
and a lot of this that's where your
commitment kind of goes into like you've
got compatibility and you've got
commitment right and compatibility on
its own doesn't cannot keep a marriage
together forever commitment on its own
can
like there are people who hate each
other but because they don't believe in
divorce they're just going to be
together forever I think that the
beautiful marriages are the ones in
which there is a compatibility and that
compatibility can grow because you
change over time that's coupled with a
commitment that then there are these
beautiful moments of light we actually
love each other have a great time too
with each other but that's not always
gonna happen because I'm a human you're
a human I'm gonna be an [ __ ] you're
gonna be an [ __ ] and in those moments
to get through the [ __ ] moments you
guys think you mean you got it that's
when you gotta have that commitment in
place and the only thing I'm saying is
the commitment to a crazy it was to look
at these couples and make a decision
about eligibility I would add that it's
a commitment to a couple of things it's
not just a commitment to staying
together I think it's a it's a
commitment to being you know it's it's
the reason why there are valves it's
like you commit to the certain things
that you're going to do you serve and
love the other person place their needs
before your needs in sickness and in
health like that sickness thing that's
that can get real tough right yeah and
if you know so if and that's a huge
commitment and it's a blind commitment
and for most people who haven't you know
care for someone who's really been sick
so I think it's it's the commitment to
those things that that you're that
you're promising that you're gonna put
them that you're gonna make it work I'm
committed to to dancing with you you
know sometimes the music is gonna suck
sometimes our lives are gonna be broken
you know but we're gonna what we're
we're committed to dancing together
through life well and I that's that's
something that it requires constant
cooperation and fidelity well and I
think that the the thing that is
difficult for a lot of couples is
and this this should be incorporated in
it into the more traditional Val's if it
isn't communica Mittman to communicate
right and I don't and I think that
people have a difficult time and this
can be personality based but you know
how sometimes when you're having a
difficult moment with someone who's a
friend anything any relationship and
sometimes what you have to do is you
have to have that meta conversation you
have to talk about the way that you talk
to each other you have to be like you
have to sit some couples get to a place
where oh we're not really communicating
we're not connecting anymore
and we have lost the ability to talk
about the fact that we're not connecting
anymore and I think that that happens in
so many relationships right it's like if
you stop talking about the nature of
your connection it's gonna be very
difficult to get the connection back
without first addressing that directly
if you just focused on the superficial
stuff the specifics of the current
argument that you're in but you haven't
you haven't gotten to the how do you
actually connect and how you communicate
solving this particular problem is not
going to be helpful it's just gonna be
it's gonna just kick the can down the
road you know and I and I think that's
what you were getting out earlier with
the marriage counseling is like what it
helps you having a third party a lot of
times oh we can have the uncomfortable
conversation that week for some reason
can't have with it just the two of us
right you break through to that and
night
it's another plane not just premarital
but like marriage therapy it's very good
you know you're yeah sometimes you just
have to bring in a third person and my
therapist is my wife's therapist which
is not necessarily advisable across the
board but in our our situation because a
lot of the times what we're doing is
we're talking about each other is like
well my therapist has the other side of
the story and then occasionally if it's
there's like an acute issue we'll both
go in together and that and that has
been that has been helpful I think
knowing that most relationships I'm not
gonna say all this entropy right of it
okay you know this isn't gonna last
forever because we're both imperfect
people that have are prone to
selfishness and yeah we're not we're not
the same person and we you know there's
so many variables you never know what
could be thrown at us as a couple so
then it's just having this mentality
like okay if that's the tendency then we
have to be vigilant about the threats to
our relationship from internal and
external and just know that okay we're
gonna you know we're gonna identify and
we're gonna we're gonna face these
threats head-on and not just because we
know that that's that's what's most
likely to happen is that something's
going to come it something's going to
sneak up on you and in a few months
you're like okay there's there's a wall
that's built up mmm this is this is a
this is a threat to our marriage
long-term it's not just leading to a bad
week or a bad month right right so I I
you know I felt like I had this very
heightened commitment Chrissy's parents
are still together you know my parents
were in my experience we're never
together and so I just you know I had
this I had this mentality that like I
was gonna like I was gonna stay
committed like I wasn't a divorce was
never an option and I I mean I don't I
haven't reassessed all of that mentality
maybe there's some negative aspects to
that and I think you can lean on that
and it's like and it minimizes the
amount of work that goes into it you
just can't say well divorce is not an
option like we've already talked about
that's not how you dance just by saying
well I'm just gonna I'm gonna stand here
and I'm gonna be here that's not dancing
well and I think
you hear this thumb around but I mean I
don't know if it's true I don't know
what the latest statistics are but I
always heard when I was in the church
that the divorce rate inside and outside
of the church is about the same I don't
I always found that hard to believe just
because I didn't see as much divorce in
the circles that I was in because it
felt like people were more committed
because they did have this sort of
ideological underpinning that included
divorce is not an option and I do think
that there is a there is a dark side to
that because a lot of times it ends up
being and I witnessed this not not with
friends but just with people that we
like knew in church where there would be
like this person is being emotionally
maybe even physically abused sure sure
and yet they're staying in this marriage
because they have this ideological
commitment and that's that's for the
Laura but or for the kids or for other
reasons or you know right but as it
applies to us III think that because I
mean I my parents are still together
Jesse's parents are still together so I
didn't have that same sort of like well
I'm gonna be different but I thought the
same mentality that you did to the
marriage is like it is nice to have it
off the table you know where it's you
know where you agree from the beginning
from before the beginning of being
married that like divorce under normal
normal circumstances is is not an option
it's not what we're not going to use it
as a relational escape hatch it's a it's
a last resort yeah and I do think that
there is again and this is not when it
comes to relational death I'm not I'm
not judging anybody or no and I'm not
prescribing anything I would have a
difficult time you know obviously kids
change the picture because now you've
got you you've you've got some people
who are gonna be affected especially if
they're kids that you're currently
raising they're in the house but if it's
a couple that again just like Mary and
this show which this has become an ADD
for this show unintentionally but like
okay
if you believe that getting married and
getting divorced on a television show is
wrong then I can't argue with that I'm
not gonna change your mind about that
but if you think that these people came
into this on their own volition
then they together made the decision
they weren't compatible they haven't
brought any kids into this yet and then
they make a decision to mutually
separate and get divorced then I'm not
gonna be like well you have dishonored
the institution of marriage by doing
that and I'm also gonna say that if you
know if it's somebody everyone has their
own reasons for it but I think that it's
the idea that this committed this is
like this isn't just a serious thing
this is a commitment that through all
these potential circumstances that we're
gonna stay together because if we don't
think like that we're gonna see a way
out
and then in the in your lowest moments
you will you can might go for the door
if you've installed the door but if
you've never installed the door you're
not gonna leave but you know what you
could decide at a certain point in a
relationship together
hey let's install the door if you come
to that conclusion as a couple and
you're like I think that we need to
seriously consider that we may not maybe
we're not supposed to be in relationship
with each other there was a time in my
life when I subscribed to an evangelical
worldview where I would be like that's
the devil talking you can't go there
because that's you now you're talking
about building the escape hatch and
you're gonna do it and I perspective one
that has changed it's like it's not my
role to judge other couples and how they
go about yeah right but what I can say
from speaking from my own experience is
that not building the escape hatch not
putting the door in has been one of the
reasons I can point to for being married
for 19 years for me yeah and and for me
too yeah I do get I you know I'm sure
that there's people in our position who
were saying similar things and then down
the road they get divorced of course you
know even that couple that I was making
all these assumptions about because
there
public and now they're saying they're
friends and you know it's just that's
just me bringing my assumptions to it I
don't even know their names what are
their names let's say I'm it I mean it
it does get complicated and I you know I
don't I do want to make a commitment to
not to not judge other people I mean cuz
it's like who have been or are going
that's a fourth I think that's clear
because what I hear you and me saying is
that if what you have collectively
decided to do is this
then there are certain decisions that
you can make to help make that reality
become a reality right that idea become
a reality but but everything that you've
made together decide that you want a
different reality yeah but well because
everything that we're that we said seems
to imply that this that that the
highroad is to stay married forever
married forever and i used to think that
and there is something beautiful about
it I'm not gonna argue with that and I
do think there is something beautiful
about like overcoming adversity and like
just the nature of commitment but you
know what
there's plenty of examples of people who
were in a difficult marriage not just
necessarily one that they needed to get
out of for like safety reasons but just
people who mutually discovered that they
wanted something different and now
they're in there each and other
beautiful committed relationships that's
a reality as well and I'm in and there
was a time in my life again if you
subscribe to a sort of a conservative
evangelical worldview then if you really
read certain parts of the Bible in a
certain way then those marriages after
divorce are illegitimate marriages yeah
and I'm glad that I don't have to think
that anymore because the observational
you know my experience is that no
actually some of those marriages are
better and healthier and better for
these people and better for the world
than the previous marriage yeah I'm not
going to cancel that marriage because I
got some ideological commitment yeah how
do you think my mom felt over the years
when like culturally we were in
environment where it was like you can't
I mean that's you failed right you've
something is wrong with you twice right
you know you're in your third marriage
now it's like you failed twice you know
and that's that's not what happened and
in many places you're not qualified to
be in leadership if that you if you're
in a relationship like that so that
you've kind of like you've got this mark
on you and you can never recover I mean
I think we've said everything through
the filter of the loop through the lens
of we do we love our wives and they love
us and that's that's who I want to I
want to be with Christie until I die you
know cuz she'll already be dead
no or until she dies I mean I just want
to cover the bases until one of us dies
it's called til til death do us harm
yeah I don't want to I don't want to
start like they took care of that a lot
Gibbs on who dies first yeah it's not
until I or you die it's till death do us
part
yeah that makes it you don't have to
think about who dies first yeah you just
say that because you don't want to have
to unravel that I told Jesse she's
younger than me I'm tall I'm gonna die
first I mean that's just I'm just going
with the stats you know tall people
don't live that long
sorry so it gets very upset once I start
talking lies so commitment looks
different for her than it does for you
yeah I might listen if things go as
according to just like nature you're
gonna have at least a few years to just
find a new man how does that feel you
know but yeah I mean you're joking now
he hates when I thought I'd love joke
with her but with her about it yeah
because she says things like well if I
died how long would it take you to get
married and and then I say things like I
don't know if I would get married and
then she gets really mad oh really
because she wants you to get married she
don't want you to be what a philanderer
or a playboy I don't know I and I was
like I thought about it cross that
bridge if we get there you know what I'm
saying but like I don't know I'm a
different person yeah I'm well I think
if you're honest though I think what you
would say I know what you would say
you'd say well I've been watching this
I've couldn't go on and it seems that
season three of married at first sight
is everyone is a widower or a widow oh I
think I just gave you all a good idea uh
that's gonna get real heavy it's the
talk about talk about crying while
you're watching and now you got to hear
all the stories yeah how their spouse
died that's I mean but as a producer
what they have to think about it
it's they've been talking about it oh
yeah hopefully a producer of married at
first sight is listening in so we ended
up just talking about marriage you know
we we talked about marriage but we
really just talking about our marriages
I mean I talked about those four
marriages on that television show as
well I mean my name really get into
specifics yeah so is that your
recommendation this week this what's the
name of the television show I don't know
range I'm gonna give him the range I'm
gonna give another recommendation on top
of that what is the name of the show
it's married at first sight it's on
Netflix I can only vote for the most
recent season I don't know what season
that is it might be season two I'm only
four episodes in but I do have another
wreck that goes back to what we were
talking about before which is some of
the things that we continue to be
dealing with as a society for the
betterment of our society and it's a
book that I am has I made it a
recommendation in my letter to a white
man that I wrote but I'm gonna talk
about it specifically here and that is
I'm still here
black dignity in a world made for
whiteness by Austin Channing brown and
this book I'm just gonna read the
description here that was made by
whoever wrote this particular review the
hello sunshine book pick Reese's book
club from a leading voice on racial
justice an eye-opening account of
growing up black Christian and female
that exposes how white America white
America's love affair with diversity so
often falls short of its ideals and I
know that you started this book as well
but the the the general idea of the book
is exactly what was just described there
that we can come to this place and this
is something that is happening in the
midst of the movement right now where a
bunch
white people can be like yes we value
diversity and we and we believe that
that is a that is something that should
be represented in our circles of friends
and our businesses in our society and in
our leadership and our legislature is
the right thing to say and it's an easy
thing to say right now but it's one her
point is challenging to an act
she tells from a very personal
perspective what it has been like to be
in white spaces as a black woman in
spaces that said that this is what they
valued and maybe even thought that this
is what they valued but didn't
understand what that actually meant it's
incredibly challenging it's incredibly
eye-opening I think it actually I don't
know if it was a New York Times
bestseller from the beginning or if it
has become a New York Times bestseller
in the midst of this movement but it is
a New York Times bestseller because it's
two years old but it is really sort of
experiencing this new wave of interest
because it speaks so directly to the
movement that is happening right now and
I think more importantly or you eat you
know even more importantly for a couple
of white dudes like us is asking the
question of what does moving beyond
valuing diversity to making diversity
and inclusivity and sort of
deconstructing this you know white is
the norm mentality that a lot of us have
without even realizing it what does it
take to break that down what is it what
does it take to move beyond that because
that's the real work that needs to
happen it's not just recognizing the
race the racial injustice it's doing
something about it and real change so
I'm still here by Austin Channing brown
and it is a pretty easy read so no
excuses for not checking this one out
wherever you check out books yeah or you
could just buy the book as well don't
just check it out all right we'll speak
at you again next week and please as
always contribute a conversation using
hashtag ear biscuits yes to watch more
ear biscuits click on the playlist on
the right to watch the previous episode
of your biscuits click on the playlist
to the left and
don't forget to click on the circular
icon to subscribe if you prefer to
listen to this podcast it's available on
all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]